everyone and welcome back to the channel
this is your host Oppenheimer as they
call me because the way I've been
farting these days is like I'm dropping
nuclear bombs uh on a more serious note
thank you all for 10 000 subscribers
means a lot to me incredible feedback
still on the channel which I'm really
happy about and I hope to do more
collaborations in the future the more
subscribers I have the less foot
pictures I have to sell so that may be
some bad news for some of you but for me
probably a nice thing anyways let's get
into some systems design today we'll be
talking about stream joins alright so
like I mentioned today we're going to be
talking about stream enrichment so
stream enrichment really just means
instead of taking an individual stream
event and passing it around through all
of these other parts of our system what
we're actually aiming to do is augment
that event with more information from
other pieces of our system
so again so far what we've looked at is
you know just having one producer one
consumer and a broker connecting them
but the reality of the situation is that
data is often coupled there are
relationships between the data and a lot
of times we might publish an event to
one consumer but on that consumer we
might want to you know add other pieces
to that data so we can pass it to other
places within our system Downstream and
you know have that piece of data be more
useful
so really what stream enrichment
effectively means is we want to perform
a join on our events with some other
pieces of data so basically what are
some examples of joins that we might be
doing in streams we're going to take a
look at three and talk about all three
of those so the first is going to be
stream stream joins so the unique thing
about these are that we're actually
matching events from two streams and the
example that I have absolutely
plagiarized from designing a data
intensive applications is basically one
where we've got one source or one
producer node that is publishing a bunch
of Search terms let's imagine I go into
Google and I type something like tissues
and a second that every single time I
click a link from Google is going to
publish the link that I clicked so that
we can later do some aggregation down
the line and look at how certain Search
terms and links interact with one
another you know whether a certain
search term might lead to more clicks or
anything like that or the average number
of clicks per search term anything like
that doesn't really matter so an example
of a link clicked would be amazon.com
so let's imagine then that for both of
those producers they're publishing
events right this would be an example of
an event and those events have a key in
this case it would be the user ID
and basically we want to be able to join
those events by key but of course it's
not enough to basically just handle
events and then say hey have we seen an
event from the other producer that
matches these why because well they
don't come in at the same time there's
some arbitrary
amount of time
where one event is valid right
you know let's say we wanted to hold on
to this guy for five minutes or
something
well where are we actually going to hold
it because if we don't hold it how are
we ever going to match it with any other
type of event we need to store it
somewhere and so typically what we'll
actually do is go ahead and store that
in the consumer so let's imagine that
this guy over here user 22 and tissues
came in first well what we would
actually do is cache that guy on our
consumer so that when 22 Amazon comes in
we can say oh wait
let's look at our hash map is there any
key with the value 22 oh there is let's
join them and then of course from there
the whole point is to enrich this data
augment it and then send it to other
parts of our system we can put it into
something like this over here which we
can call a sync queue so this queue is
just going to lead to other parts of our
system with our augmented data Okay so
we've covered stream stream joins where
effectively in our consumer we want to
Cache the results of both streams hold
on to those and then join them as new
events come in what are we going to do
for this stream table joins so stream
table joins are exactly what they sound
like effectively now what we want to do
instead of just using a stream and a
stream is we want to take the events
from one stream that are coming in and
actually join them with data that exists
in a database table so what would be
another example of doing this well for
starters let's imagine we've got a
similar event to last time right so
we've got Search terms
and then let's say we want to actually
go ahead and join those with the
demographics
of the person who is going to be
searching
so for example over here the primary key
is going to be the user ID in both cases
and so we've got this event
right from our database the reason we're
actually able to do this is because if
you recall from a couple of videos ago
what we can do with databases is
something called change data capture
and change data capture is going to
serve us in a few ways the reason being
that the naive solution to a stream
table join is to forget about this whole
thing right and instead every single
time that the consumer receives an event
it could make a network call
to the database
and that has one main issue which is the
network calls are slow
we don't want to have to query the
database every single time we receive an
event on our consumer because it's
extremely slow we would rather save much
more time process more events increase
the latency and throughput of our system
and so what we do instead is on our
consumer a better solution would be this
guy right here we keep an in-memory copy
of the database table we actually
perform some caching and that is going
to bring up a pretty obvious issue which
is consistency
how do we actually make sure that our
in-memory copy of our database table is
up to date because I might change the
demographic info for Jordan I might have
a birthday and now my age becomes 23 or
something
the way we do this again is change data
caps capture so a write goes to our
database that's step one the database
propagates that event step two to a
message broker
and then from there what's actually
going to happen is the message broker
can then be consumed by the consumer who
can now actually go ahead and update the
in-memory copy of the database table so
that when an event is received from our
stream we can actually perform our join
and then send it to some outbound queue
and this is going to greatly lower our
latency so using something like change
data capture turning a source of data
like a database into effectively another
stream allows us to make sure that we're
getting the minimum possible latency and
the maximum possible throughput in
processing all of these stream events so
now we have one more type of join to
touch upon and that is actually going to
be table to table joins now you may
think to yourself well why the hell do
we need streams for table to table
joints we can already just do that in a
SQL database and you would be completely
correct However the fact of the matter
is that database tables change over time
right and so let's say we want to make
sure that the result of our join is as
up to date as possible at all times Well
if we had a SQL database the naive
solution would just be polling
every five seconds or something
we run our query
and that's not great for a couple of
reasons for starters it's not real time
right we have to periodically run our
result second of all that's running a
massive query because we're doing a huge
join across two tables wouldn't it be a
lot better if incrementally as new
rights came in we could just join them
with the other table as need be as
opposed to having to redo an entire
massive query every few seconds well the
answer to that is probably going to be
yes so what do we do well basically we
can use change data capture
twice
which is pretty huge for us
so as you can see we've got table one
over here
we've got table two over here and every
single right that comes in is then going
to be propagated
to our message Brokers one for each
table
and then of course this way what we can
do is actually go ahead and cache on our
consumer copies of both tables now you
may think to yourself and you would be
correct well Jordan what if these tables
are too big to be held in memory on a
single consumer well then we would have
to basically do some partitioning
where we would split all of our cues
into multiple different pieces and then
probably we would have to have one
consumer per partition as long as
everything is partitioned in the same
way we'll be good to go
so yeah as you can see table table joins
are a really effective way of making
sure that you have up-to-date joined
data as the rights actually come in as
opposed to having to run a query on an
incremental batch job which is huge
so what are the patterns that we
actually see with stream joins well in
all three of those cases that we just
mentioned above there's one main
similarity which is that effectively
we've got some sort of state and we are
going to Cache it in memory on our
consumer in memory generally speaking
because that allows us to have maximum
performance in theory you could do it on
disk but sometimes this makes things
hard for joining unless things are all
sorted the same way so ideally you would
keep things in a hash map on memory and
perform joins via a hash join so this
leads us to a couple of issues and one
of them I just touched upon which is
that whenever you're storing things in
memory we've got a whole lot less space
on each consumer which is a problem
because our database tables are pretty
big especially if we want to do a stream
table or a table table join and as a
result of that we may have to actually
have many many consumers and many many
partitions of cues where each consumer
and each partition of cues are lined up
with one another as you know we might
expect so for example you might have all
the a keys on one cue and one consumer
all the B keys on another queue and
another consumer and partition like that
somehow
that being said obviously that's still
just a tough thing to do it's a lot of
things to keep organized there might be
a lot of overhead and of course issue
number two again is that whenever we're
keeping all of our data in memory
consumer state is not fault tolerant
why well because it's in memory so if a
consumer goes down we lose all of the
cash data that it had and then we would
have to somehow get it back which you
know depending on the type of message
broker that we're using is not always
possible even having a right ahead log
isn't necessarily enough the reason
being that we have multiple partitions
of consumers and as a result even if
we're able to bring back our old State
on one consumer the other partitions of
consumers might be far ahead of it and
have processed more messages and now
they're basically out of sync with one
another
so the kind of question is here well we
have a ton of partitions to manage and
we need to be able to achieve fault
tolerance how can we do it and that
right there is going to be the topic of
our next video which is all about Apache
flank and stateful stream processing
Solutions so I will see you guys for the
next one again everyone thank you so
much for 10K genuinely means a lot to me
love teaching you guys love getting good
feedback and I love interacting with you
all in the comments so let's keep it up
I'll see you all soon